There are two fundamental
pieces of technology
that enable progressive web apps
to be reliable, fast and engaging.
Service workers and
the Web App Manifest File.
Let's take a look at
service workers first.
Most web apps are built
on a client-server model.
Without a server there is no web app.
But service workers changes that.
Service workers are a progressive
enhancement for the network staff, and
sit between the browser and the server.
Acting as a client side
proxy written in JavaScript.
That means you can cache assets locally.
So no matter what kind of
network the user's connected to,
apps load near instantly.
Apps can even work offline
because the service worker
will respond to network requests.
Once a service worker is registered,
it can do more than just
as a client side proxy.
You can define what
events will wake it up.
Events like push messages can
wake up a service worker and
re-engage the user with notifications.
Or data can be seamlessly
synced to your servers
when a network connection is restored.
And what's amazing is that they don't
rely on the web app being open in a tab,
or even a browser being open on mobile.
Service workers are to progressive web
apps, as XMLHttpRequest was to Ajax.
They give progressive web apps
the power to exist beyond the browser.
The second fundamental piece of
technology is the web app manifest file,
which gives you the ability to control
how your app appears to the user
in areas where they would
expect to see apps.
And more importantly,
how they can launch it.
When a set of heuristics are met,
the web app install banner
will even prompt users to add
your app to their home screen.
Then when the user opens it from
the home screen, it opens full-screen,
no browser UI.
And it's a top level app
in the task switcher.
So it feels just like any other app.